so what risk do you think that cheating
is sort of posing to the game of chess
because engines are so much better at
humans cheating is sort of a existential
risk I think between the very top
players there's still a pretty good
level of of trust that people are
playing fair but I know that at other
other levels the trust is considerably
less and it it is frustrating for
players to to have these thoughts in the
in the back of their Minds that um yeah
if somebody you don't know suddenly
plays really well yeah it inevitably
Creeps in I try not to think too much
about what cheating is going on in title
Tuesday and other events I simply don't
know I think that chess is doing quite
well in general but I do think that
cheating is like even if it's not that
big a problem right now I think it is
like the existential threat to the game
and it doesn't really go away